I don't think we live
in a world anymore
where there is one path
to drive successful life.
Entrepreneurs come from all shapes
and walks of life.
And we see that daily
with companies that thrive
and companies that, you know, perish.
Shahar Erez, thank you for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing well.
How are you, Michael?
Good morning.
I'm doing wonderful.
Thank you very much.
Let's talk about Talent.
Let's talk about the workplace,
talent, data driven talent acquisition
and hybrid models.
Because what you're doing
with Stoke Talent is fascinating.
But right before we get there,
let's go back to you journey
just a little bit.
From the Technion
and finishing 12 years of studies
getting your high school diploma
at the age of 22.
You will not really think
that a 22 year old graduate
will end up being
a successful tech veteran?
What is that about?
Neither did my parents.
They were pretty concerned
when I graduated high school
without a diploma.
But you know, during high school
my mind was at a different place.
I didn't enjoy studying.
Although I was registered
to study physics and computers,
it's kind of a great class considered
but my mind was elsewhere.
I was already thinking about going
to the military service.
And so, I actually didn't wake up
to my final math test in high school.
And so I never,
Wow.
I never officially graduated.
I did almost five years
in the military, various roles.
And when I left,
I think I was already
a little more mature
and understood that
if I want to do something
with my life,
I better complete that.
By the way, the day
that I left the military,
I remember my parents calling me like,
"If you want to double think that
when you don't,
you won't get any job outside.
Why don't you stick in the military?"
And so, I did leave the military.
I completed my high school diploma.
I did my math, physics exams.
And went and did my
psychometric exam.
I guess it's the equivalent of an SAT.
I got a pretty good score.
Kind of, you know,
combined with my military service,
paved the way to get
a full three year scholarship
for computer science.
Although I never wanted
to study computer science,
I thought it was going to be boring.
But somehow I got
a full three year scholarship.
And that's how I got
into computer science.
One thing led to the other.
And I was never a great engineer.
I never thought I will be
a great engineer but it gave me,
you know, it gave me insights
into this entire, back then you know,
high tech industry,
what does it mean.
And there's more than just coding.
There's an entire ecosystem around it.
Got to work with a lot of people,
startup companies, large companies.
How business get built around software,
the various elements that are required.
How do you build a product.
How do you go sell a product.
How you market a product.
And so, I was fortunate to work
from my perspective
with the best of the best
you know, joint companies
like Mercury Interactive.
I was mentored by leaders,
probably the best leaders in the industry.
People like [--], Amnon Landan.
Then in VMware,
with people like Paul Maritz.
I was really
had the opportunity to learn
from these people.
How to think about business,
how to think about leading people,
what should you focus on,
what should you give up on,
what to insist and you know.
Shahar, would you do anything differently?
If you were to go back
to high school, middle school,
would you do anything differently?
You know, I'm not sure.
Yes, you might say I wasted some time.
But I don't think anything
could have been different.
Some things need to happen
in their own pace.
The only thing I regret is
I never graduated quite cool.
Other than that I don't really care
about anything else.
My kids now, I have three kids now,
all in their teens.
And although school is important,
we never really look at their grades.
I don't really make it a thing.
I think that there's so much more
at driving successful happy life
than you know, how much you scored
on your English, math
or whatever exam.
I think that,
I'm living testimony to someone
that flunked math in school.
And, you know, my parents
were called in to school multiple times.
It just took some time for me
to get settled in and, you know,
to find my way.
And I think that
the most important thing is to find
how should I say it,
find your passion,
be a good person.
And beyond that,
I mean, there's multiple things
that need to be done.
I don't think we live
in a world anymore
where there is one path
to drive successful life.
Entrepreneurs come from all shapes
and walks of life.
And we see that daily
with companies that thrive
and companies that, you know, perish.
And there's no one path for that.
It's not that you have to go
to these schools
and you have to study these things
and you have to take this track.
It's mostly about the person you are.
The interaction that
you are able to create with others.
Your ability to think outside the box.
I think that a lot of these things
are not things that you acquire
in traditional education.
But you acquire them
through different experiences in life.
Which, by the way,
would lead to some of my observation
around where the talent market
is heading.
A lot of who I am today is an outcome.
That is going to be my next question.
Obviously, it's not because
of what I've studied at school,
but it's because
of the experiences I had
both in school
and then in my military service
with the people
I had the opportunity
to interact with.
And then being fortunate to work
for the company
with the people I worked with
and how much I was open
to learn from them,
to get feedback,
to do better at what I do.
And it's not specifically
about getting this grade
or that grade.
It's one of the things
you study in Israeli air force is,
it doesn't matter how successful
your last flight was.
It's like, can you come off that flight,
spend time to research
what was wrong.
Research what went well,
keep what went well
and fix what went wrong
for your next flight.
And then on an ongoing basis,
how do you create
ongoing improvement.
You know, I think without
applying the specific approach
on a day to day basis,
this was the mentality
that I've absorbed
over the last 20 years.
Sometimes I succeeded to what I did.
And a lot of times I failed.
I've built products that didn't succeed.
I've built products
that were extremely successful,
but what can you learn from it.
Right.
I think one of the things
that I was always so hugely impressed
doing during my service
and I was always looking
at the Air Force debriefing methodology
that you were referring to.
And I think that it's been quoted
countless times by Eric Schmidt
and [--] and others,
they were talking about
this behavior mechanism
where it doesn't matter
if you succeeded or failed,
there's always something
to learn from this experience.
And unless you're very intentional
with the way that you debrief
this experience,
you can let the lessons
just fly by you
and then it's worthless
because you didn't learn anything, right?
Then where's the compounding learning
along your life.
And I agree.
It's so important there
and it's the debrief.
And one of the most important things
with that debrief is,
how do you debrief
leaving your ego aside.
Because we have this
internal defensive mechanism.
It's like, it wasn't me,
something else went wrong.
Right.
And I met at some point
it wasn't in my unit,
but one of the elite units
in the military.
And a friend there kind of told me,
It's the first thing you do in debrief.
It's like you go up on stage
and say, "I failed, I was wrong."
Once you do that,
you come with that approach,
then your egos aside,
and then you learn and evolve.
And I try to apply that.
And then moving on,
it's like 15 years later,
I heard Paul Maritz back at VMware
which is one of the nicest person,
one of the smartest person
people that I know and he said,
"How do you grow up as a leader
not spending every minute
at work trying to be
the smartest person in the room?
How do you leave that aside?"
It's like it doesn't matter
who's right, who's wrong.
How do you end a conversation
in a different manner?
And I think, some of it
has to do with maturity.
Some of it has to do
with obviously attitude and DNA.
But once you rise
to that level of not really
putting yourself at the center
but you're just a piece of that puzzle,
a lot of things inside and around you
start moving a lot better.
And I think that
that's very, very smart.
And I'm definitely taking that to heart.
Shahar, tell me a little bit about
your insights into the talent space.
What is the talent space to start with?
Because I don't meet many entrepreneurs
that are working in that space.
Yeah.
So, I'll tell you,
my, obviously my POV.
So, you know, I spent 20 years almost
in the industry leading teams.
Hundreds of people
in some of those phases.
And the one thing
that you see along the line
is the one thing
that I think distinguishes
super successful companies
with a less successful companies
is their ability
to deploy the right talent,
at the right project
at the right time
to produce the right results.
And what I've seen, and I work
for large corporates and small companies
is that it's very difficult
to navigate this talent pool
because the resources that you need
are not the resources that you have.
And then you start doing
you know, all this maneuvering
instead of fitting the business,
fitting your existing talent pool.
Back in 2013,
when I moved back to Israel
from California,
I started my own company
and we bootstrapped
because we can't raise any money.
And we started using online marketplaces.
It was early days for Fiverr.
oDesk was still
the leading platform, I think.
We started getting exposure
to different online marketplace
where you can find talent.
After a bit of trial and error,
because it gets time
to get adjusted to these,
we found tremendous value
in online platform.
Because all of a sudden
if I need something,
I have someone working on it
the next day.
Maybe they're not perfect for it.
But if I had to go and recruit for
somebody to do that job,
I'd be waiting three months.
Or we get something 70%
of the quality,
but starts working on it
within 48 hours.
And that kind of change,
Even less.
Yeah, even less.
It depends what you need. Right?
If you need a a piece of code
and sometimes you need
to qualify them and so forth.
But you kind of change
your entire month.
So, we built a company
that started getting traction.
At some point we decided to drop it.
But it wasn't because
we weren't able to execute.
At some point we had 18 people
working for us
all the way from New York, Rochester.
All the way to India, Bangladesh,
Indonesia, all over the world.
We had 18 people working for us
from design to coding.
And we found that
the ability to execute
grows exponentially
when you adopt that approach.
Further on, I joined back
into the corporate life
and try to apply that approach
into corporate, didn't work.
Corporates work on a different stages,
different processes.
And I found that to be
a disabler for companies
to get to their full potential.
And we kind of said,
"What if we can connect this world
of infinite talent pools?"
Because really,
there's hundreds of millions
highly qualified people
around the world wanting to freelance.
On the other hand,
there is a need for talent,
how do we connect the two together,
not through the traditional marketplace
that exists right now
which is more of a consumer based
swipe your credit card,
get someone to do work,
but really in a robust manner
for what corporates need to do.
So, we embarked on this journey to say,
what if we built
an enterprise grade mechanism
that helps companies
A, take control over their existing
freelancers and contractors;
and B, augment
their existing execution processes
with external freelancers.
The biggest challenge
that we saw out there
was the internal organizational processes
for companies, unlike consumers,
require a different process.
Because, you know, Michael,
if you need someone
to do slides for you
or get a video for you
or swipe your credit card on Fiverr,
someone will do that for you.
If you want to do that,
we need Hippo, for example,
do you have the budget?
Do you have the permissions?
Do you know which paperwork
these freelancers need to sign?
Can you assure that IP will be owned
by Hippo at the end of the process?
There's a set of questions
that come with it
that the company has to comply with
to be able to take that value.
The best example I can give is,
think about Amazon 12 years ago.
You're young,
you're far younger than I am.
So, I don't know where you were
when Amazon emerged back in 2007,
give or take 2008.
But when Amazon started,
up until that point,
if you wanted to build
an application at a company
you needed to get servers.
To get a server,
you need to go to IT.
IT sent you back to finance
to get budget approval
and then you went back to IT
that gave you the spec
that they can support,
then you went and submitted
the purchase order.
Six weeks later, you had a server
and you could start coding.
The day after Amazon emerged,
if you wanted to build an application,
all you do is click a few buttons.
What has changed in the process?
You know, I think that actually
that exact different you know,
I experienced that being
in the 8200 units
where, you know, it's on prime
and it's still,
it's not there but we have to do it
and then a day after,
you know, getting out of it,
all of a sudden you have everything
in the click of a button.
So, that mental shock,
what you've experienced,
I think over 12 years,
I've experienced in one day.
But I think that's just the nature
of the different talents.
I agree.
And if you think about it,
the biggest difference,
I mean, it's not that Amazon
is far cheaper.
But there's two significant differences.
Number one,
everything that you do on Amazon
is fully tracked, sort of digitized.
You click a button,
you bought the service,
someone sees it,
someone can monitor it.
Someone can come to you
and say, "Hey, Michael,
did you buy this service?"
Everything is fully visible.
Nothing goes hidden.
Everything that you bought today,
you can decide
if you don't need tomorrow
you return it.
The same thing is now happening
in the world with talent.
If you need someone to help you,
I know what part of Hippo
you're working on,
if you need someone
an expert in NLP tomorrow
to help you solve a problem,
you can and go find someone
to help you solve that NLP problem.
It's going to cost you
a few hundred dollars.
It's going to accelerate your work
by three or four days,
and then you let him go.
It's the same exact thought process.
Everything is managed.
Just like but like you're mentioning,
there is a whole added layer
of complexity because
it's not just the expertise,
but there's compliance issues
with the data that we're working with.
And there is, you know,
a lot of it is based around the privacy
and the intellectual property
of the company.
And I'm assuming that
with an example like you're giving,
if you're requesting
the aid of an expert ad hoc,
then this is probably dealing
with some sensitive data
or some core business
that you really need to dig deep.
And therefore, you also need
to be extra careful with who
you are submitting the information.
That's a great comment.
And this is exactly where Stoke comes in.
Part of what Stoke built,
because we're optimized
for these corporates and companies,
is to help the company
set their policy.
Who's allowed to be freelancer
in the company,
what people do you need this time,
which states can they come from,
what validation and background check
will the platform run on them
before they get started,
all of that in a fully automated manner.
Another example I can give you
is think about when you're traveling
between Stanford and Tel Aviv
and wherever it is you're going,
and if you're going on a private trip
you're booking your flight through
an Expedia or Booking
or whatever platform
you're using for your personal travel.
If you're booking at trip for Hippo,
you're probably doing it
using a Trip actions, or that sort.
The difference is
at the end of the day,
everyone's boarding the same flight.
But the internal controls, mechanisms,
validations, policies, budgeting,
all of that is different
between a personal trip
and a corporate trip.
And this is where the corporate element
of handling talents and freelancer
is the layer that Stoke has built.
To make sure that everyone's working
for the company is valid.
Everyone is legal, now with AB5
or Prop 22 in California
make sure that
they can actually be paid
as independent contractor.
Making sure they signed the right IP,
documents. or you own your IP
at the end of the process.
Make sure they got paid on time
so you're not violating
payment legislation.
This is exactly the layer
that we add.
So, if you or anyone else in the company
needs to get extra help or resources,
they don't have to go through legal,
finance, HR, procurement
and wait for months
before they can actually get going.
How do you actually create
that marketplace where,
because it sounds like the onboarding
for these contractors,
you can call them as well
as the companies,
is not a one click, right?
I mean, you have to vet the person.
You have to make sure
that they have compliance
with all of the taxes
and all the payment methods.
And you also have to make sure
that they're also sending
the right IP contract.
So, it does sound complicated.
How do you simplify the process
for both the contractor
and the company that contracts?
Great question. There's two sides.
A, we're not trying to become
a marketplace ourselves.
I'm not pooling the talents myself.
Most of the companies,
we work with startup
by bringing on their own talent
to the platform, the freelancers
that they're working with right now
just to make sure
that they are complying with legislation.
And if the companies look
for additional resources,
then we're actually partnering
with the set of marketplace.
There's about six or 700 marketplaces now.
HBS just released a paper.
There's over seven hundred marketplaces.
Some of them are generic
like UpWork, Freelancer.com, Fiverr.
Some of them are more specific
or verticalized.
From our standpoint,
we're not taking a dime off a freelancer.
So, for us we're okay working
with anyone in a marketplace
in partnership.
When someone is searching for talent,
we'll go search it
from multiple marketplaces.
And when the connection is done
between the company
and the freelancer
we'll make sure that
we vet the freelancer,
we make them signed the right paperwork,
everything is happening automatically
through the platform.
So, the work will not start
before all that background check is done.
That makes a lot of sense.
I'd love to spend
the last few minutes that we have
talking a little bit about
your observation on the talent industry
as covid hit.
So, everybody's talking
about working remotely.
You know, we hear that sentence
every other day.
But I'm curious to hear
with your outlook on the hybrid model.
And not just onboarding employees
during covid
but also onboarding freelancers.
And I'm assuming intuitively
that there has been
an increase in usage of freelancers.
And I'm guessing that
a lot of companies are realizing
that, okay,
if I'm finding people online,
maybe I don't have to find the person
that's sitting in the next street.
Maybe I can just hire the person
that is 1,000 kilometers away
but is a little bit cheaper
or has a different skill set.
So, what has happened
to your industry as a result?
So, first of all, the trend was there
way before covid started.
There was a report from 2018
in the United States,
over 2500 companies
without offices in 2018.
So, this is not new.
This remote thing
didn't start with covid.
What covid, and if you look
at the reports from the IRS
and Bureau of Labor Statistics,
the projection was that by 2025,
50% of the workforce in the US
will be freelancing.
And by 2030, 60%.
So, the trajectory is there.
This is way before covid.
Wow.
What covid has done
is accelerated a five year process
into five months.
And all the indications that we're seeing
by public companies
like Fiverr and Upwork,
by Gartner, McKinsey, Deloitte,
CNBC and Harvard now
is that we're seeing 20 to 30%,
depends on who you're quoting,
growth in the number of freelancers
by these companies.
There's too many grounds here.
Number one is in set.
Everyone's remote.
So, does it matter if
I get someone to work remote
for me on payroll
or as a freelancer?
Obviously, there's a lot of benefit
in working as a freelancer.
It doesn't matter if
they're on payroll or not.
Add to that effect, generational shift.
Most of Generation Z
and a portion of Millennials
prefer to be freelancers
not be tied to a single employer.
Then there's a match of expectation.
Companies prefer the flexibility.
Individuals prefer the flexibility
because no one expects
job security anymore anyway.
So, why not have that flexibility.
And the last thing is that
companies are realizing
that it's super complicated
to run any projection.
They don't know how they're,
what is going to happen next year.
So, getting into commitment
with full time employees
versus keeping flexibility
in a world of changing skill sets,
there is expectation that skill sets
will change every two to three years.
And so, do I really need to spend now
getting people on board
that will be with me
in four to five years?
Maybe it's not the right thing
for the company anymore.
We're seeing average time
tech employees spend at the companies
has dropped one point nine years.
Just under two years,
if you think about it.
That's the average time
someone sticks to a company.
So, why not build a flexible workforce
that has 60, 70% of its employees
as full time employees,
and the other 30 to 40%
keeps changing on an ongoing basis.
Every research shows,
freelancers are more up to date
with changes in the industry.
They're more passionate
about what they do.
They execute faster.
And they on board three times faster
compared to traditional employees.
Because they're doing it constantly.
So, if that's the case,
then go on freelancers.
Start working with them.
If they're great at what they do,
try to convince them
to become full time employees.
And if they don't, get someone else.
I think that that's
an amazing way to end.
And I'm convinced.
So, Shahar, thank you very, very much
for this time.
Thank you for teaching
a little bit more than
a lot more than I knew
about about this industry.
And I think the way you're doing
at Stoke Talent
makes perfect sense to me.
Especially with the trajectories
of where we're going.
And covid-19, as you said,
it just accelerated it.
The trend was already there.
I've been actually using
oDesk since 2013.
When I had my high school startup,
we had almost 50 people
in India and Pakistan
that were working ad hoc
on all these various tasks
because we were four high schoolers
and we needed more support.
And we didn't even know
how to get real employees.
But it was very easy
to swipe a credit card
and pay somebody from oDesk.
I wish we had Stoke back then.
So, if my co-founders
are listening to this,
they know exactly what I'm talking about.
Shahar, before we leave,
I have to ask you for three words
that you would use
to describe yourself.
I'd start with assertive, empathetic,
and visionary.
Although it sounds like, you know,
I'm a bit exaggerating about myself.
But that's how I usually approach things.
I look at the long term.
I love that.
And it comes definitely across
in this conversation that
a lot of it is long term thinking.
And I love that.
But if I had to say one thing again
as a tip for others,
it's like empathy is keys.
Like, it doesn't matter what you do
and how you trying to build it.
And you're working for Hippo.
And Assaf is a great example of
beyond being the visionary and the leader.
And he's one of the smartest
people I know.
It's like the first thing
is to be a mensch.
In Yiddish,
a mensch is like be a decent person,
be a kind person.
Everything else is [--].
I'm very excited
to send this to him now.
Shahar, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
And stay safe and stay healthy.